♪ ♪
>> Juan: WELCOME BACK.
DNC REPORTEDLY DROPPING ITS
SPONSORSHIP OF THE WOMEN'S MARCH
AFTER ONE OF THE GROUP'S LEADERS
REFUSED TO RENOUNCE NATION OF
ISLAM LEADER LOUIS FARRAKHAN.
HERE WAS THE HEATED EXCHANGE
THAT TOOK PLACE TODAY.
>> I DIDN'T CALL HIM THE
GREATEST OF ALL TIME BECAUSE OF
HIS RHETORIC.
I CALLED HIM THE GREATEST OF ALL
TIME BECAUSE OF WHAT HE'S DONE
IN BLACK COMMUNITIES.
I DON'T AGREE WITH MANY OF
MR. FARRAKHAN'S STATEMENTS.
AS I SAID, I DON'T AGREE WITH
MANY OF HIS STATEMENTS.
>> DO YOU CONDEMN THEM?
>> I DON'T AGREE WITH THE
STATEMENTS.
>> YOU WON'T CONDEMN IT.
>> NO, NO, IT'S NOT MY LANGUAGE.
IT'S NOT THE WAY I SPEAK OR
ORGANIZE.
I SHOULD NEVER BE JUDGED THROUGH
THE LENS OF A MAN.
>> Juan: WHAT YOU SAW, THAT
WAS MONDAY, NOT TODAY.
WHAT YOU SEE THERE IS
REPRESENTATIVE OF A LARGER
MOVEMENT AWAY FROM THE MARCH BY
SOUTHERN POVERTY LAW CENTER,
EMILY'S LIST, HUMAN RIGHTS
CAMPAIGN, NATIONAL
ABORTION-RIGHTS LEAGUE, THESE
LEFT-LEANING GROUPS THAT HAD
SUPPORT OF THE MARCH.
THEY TURNED OUT MILLIONS IN THE
IMMEDIATE AFTERMATH OF THE
INAUGURATION.
THEY ARE PULLING AWAY.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> Lisa: CREDIT WHERE CREDIT
IS DUE, RIGHT?
GOOD FOR THEM.
AS A STARTING WITH THE WOMAN'S
MARCH, ESPECIALLY INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE ANTI-SEMITIC.
HOLDING HER FEET TO THE FIRE AND
ASKING FOR AN EXQUISITE
CONDEMNATION AND MALIKA REFUSED.
I THINK IT'S A BIG PROBLEM.
THEY ALSO HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
ANTI-SEMITES AMONG THE GROUP.
YOU HAD MAXINE WATERS, THERE'S A
VIDEO RECENTLY OF HER HUGGING
THOSE FARRAKHAN.
SHE'S THE CHAIRWOMAN OF THE
FINANCIAL SERVICES COMMITTEE.
IT SHOULDN'T BE THAT HARD TO
CONDEMN A GUY WHO SAYS JEWS ARE
TERMITES.
IT SHOULDN'T BE THAT HARD.
>> Juan: A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
THE BLACK COMMUNITY SAY WAIT A
SECOND.
NO ONE APPROVES OF LOUIS
FARRAKHAN'S ANTI-SEMITISM BUT
LOUIS FARRAKHAN AND THE NATION
OF ISLAM HAVE ALWAYS ENGAGED
POOR, PEOPLE IN JAIL, AND HELP
THOSE PEOPLE.
>> Brian: NOT SAYING THAT
EVERY PERSON WHO IS EVIL DOESN'T
DO ANY GOOD.
FARRAKHAN MIGHT HAVE ATTRIBUTES
IN THE BLACK COMMUNITY BUT
ANYONE LOOKING FOR SOMETHING
BROAD-BASED HAS TO DISASSOCIATE.
FOR THEM TO GO ON "THE VIEW,"
THINK THEY CAN MAKE THE
STATEMENTS.
HE DOES THINGS IN THE BLACK
AMENITY BUT I'M NOT FOR HIS
ANTI-SEMITIC BEHAVIOR, ANTIWHITE
TALK.
JUST GET THE LINES DOWN.
AT THE VERY LEAST, SHE WAS NOT
PREPARED TO DISASSOCIATE HERSELF
AND NOW A PROGRAM, MARCH THAT
HAD 550 SPONSORS IS DOWN TO HALF
THAT MIGHT NOT EVEN TAKE PLACE
ON SUNDAY.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
BEING FRIENDS WITH LOUIS
FARRAKHAN CAN DESTROY A LIFE, A
CAREER, PROGRAM, AND IN THIS
CASE, IT WOMAN'S MARCH.
IS IT WORTH IT?
>> Juan: IT'S DIFFICULT FOR
PEOPLE TRYING TO ACHIEVE
SOLIDARITY AS PART OF THE
ANTI-TRUMP RESISTANCE.
THE QUESTION BECOMES IF THIS IS
ABOUT RACE, WHAT ABOUT WHAT IS
GOING ON WITH STEVE KING IN THE
REPUBLICAN RANKS?
YOU SAW THEM PULL COMMITTEE
ASSIGNMENTS FROM HIM BUT HE'S
NOT BEING FORCED OUT.
HE'S NOT BEING THROWN OUT OF THE
CONGRESS.
>> Dana: HOW THEY DO THAT,
RIGHT?
HE'S BEEN ELECTED.
THEY CAN DO AS MUCH PUNISHMENT
AS THEY CAN.
THERE IS A RACE TO GET TO THE
MORAL HIGH GROUND AND THE GUILT
BY ASSOCIATION.
THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR A
LONG TIME, RIGHT?
IF YOU ARE PART OF THIS GROUP OR
THAT, YOU MUST AGREE WITH ALL OF
THE THINGS.
THE FARRAKHAN PIECE IS PRETTY
INTERESTING AND SO IS THE STEVE
KING PIECE.
YOU HAVE SOMEONE LIKE LIZ CHENEY
WHO IS THE CHAIRMAN FOR THE
REPUBLICANS, SAYING THAT YOU
SHOULD FIND ANOTHER LINE OF
WORK.
DRAWING A LINE IN THE SAND.
MAYBE DEMOCRATS SMELL BLOOD IN
THE WATER.
THEY WANT REPUBLICANS TO HURT
BECAUSE OF STEVE KING BUT THE
REPUBLICANS CAN SAY WHAT ABOUT
LOUIS FARRAKHAN.
WHERE DOES IT END?
THERE IS PERSONAL CHOICE,
RIGHTS, LIKE I DON'T HAVE TO OWN
EVERYTHING ANYONE WHO'S EVER
BEEN REPUBLICAN HAS HAD.
I CAN CHOOSE MY OWN PATH.
YOU MAKE A CHOICE 20,000 TIMES A
DAY EVERY TIME YOU OPEN YOUR
MOUTH.
>> Juan: HOW WOULD YOU HANDLE
THIS?
>> Tyrus: THE BIGGEST PROBLEM
WITH REVEREND FARRAKHAN WAS THAT
HE DID NOT EVOLVE.
IN THE '60s IN '70s, IT WAS
A DIFFERENT WORLD.
HE SHOULD HAVE EVOLVED.
HE NEEDED TO CONDEMN THE
ANTI-SEMITISM.
YOU CAN SUPPORT THE THINGS HE
DID BUT HE DIDN'T EVOLVE.
HE STAYED IN THE LANE WE ARE
TRYING NOT TO BE IN.
YOU CAN'T SUPPORT FARRAKHAN AND
THEN CONDEMN SOMEONE FOR
SUPPORTING KING.
YOU CAN'T DO IT.
IF A GUY WANTS TO BE PRO-WHITE
AND HE WANTS TO SAY BAD THINGS
ABOUT AFRICAN-AMERICANS AND
JEWISH PEOPLE BUT HE'S REALLY
GOOD AT BALANCING THE BUDGET,
YOU WILL SEE THEM MAKE THAT
ARGUMENT.
IT'S THE SAME THING.
WE HAVE COME A LONG WAY.
IT'S THE SAME PLAYING FIELD NOW
A LOT MORE THAN IT WAS 30 YEARS
AGO AND THAT RHETORIC AND HIS
FIGHT AND HIS VIGOR WAS
IMPORTANT TO THE BLACK
COMMUNITY.
HE NEED TO EVOLVE.
HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN CHANGING THE
WAY HE SPEAKING NOW BECAUSE IT
IS DIFFERENT WORLD NOW AND YOU
CAN ASK FOR CHANGE IF YOU ARE
NOT WILLING TO CHANGE.
>> Lisa: I WAS GOING TO SAY
BEFORE TWEETER OR THE MEDIA.
TO MAKE TAMIKA MALORY.
I SAID THE WRONG NAME.
>> Juan: I THINK PEOPLE WILL
AGREE WITH YOU.
THE JEWISH AND BLACK COMMUNITY
WAS THE FOREFRONT OF THE CIVIL
RIGHTS ERA.
IT'S A CULT GROUP IN MANY WAYS,
AND IT'S A PROBLEM NOW.